two three four five six seven eight nine
is that your loudest 9 i'ma keep it low
because I need my voice for the show
okay I do hour and 35 every night this
is my 28th show out of 82 so you know I
keep it real calm there's be the wyndham
called tech nine you need to check it
out right here right now bootleg Capcom
you know I'm saying we're just kicking
it like donkeys and swinging like
monkeys side 975 blazing today's hottest
music Ready Set Radio bootleg have
sitting next to me one of the illness
ever technine danina what's up brother
what's up man hey good to see you too uh
congratulations on everything dude I
would the last time I talked to you was
right when uh you're about to drop
psychology 101 wow those a minute yeah
yeah it was in Boise Idaho over here I
remember the LDS chicks yeah you
remember that huh a lot of these things
huh shout out to the latter-day saints
yeah it called me today haha said I
won't be able to come to the show call
me and I'll tell you why oh uh now uh
it's it's been you know I almost two
years and you've come so far man I mean
at that point in time you'd come so far
from you know yes it's it's just it's
like the constant evolution to tech nine
min I it keeps getting bigger and bigger
right before my eyes man you know I'm
sizzling like right what I'm thinking
I'm you know then done a lot a lot more
calm writes a blessing for real you know
I'm sizzling cuz you know to be the only
independent in the top five you know so
yeah say congratulations I you know the
numbers came out yesterday yeah number
four on the Billboard Top 200 yeah yeah
that's crazy man cuz Lincoln a radio
play our video play for real you know
saying it's crazy but my fans are
insanely crazily in love with me and and
and you've also like I'd say over the
last two years you've gotten a lot of
new fans cuz ya when it's crazy because
not even little with a little lamps and
like cuz I remember you were always like
kind of like taboo like a lot of hip hop
heads but I tech knives we were over the
last two years people are finally
starting to recognize yeah I think it
started with rock the bells and
pay dues and then Wayne said my name a
lot of people a lot more people took
notice trying to see what it is and then
they got this album said whoa you know
me and and to be like my favorite tech
nine album for what was killer kod came
out yeah and that was my favorite I know
I know you always say you're not into
the dark the dark thing you don't I
don't know I figured out that it was
gonna be here no matter what when I put
our seepage you know something yeah I've
got one to go visit jim morrison in
Paris you know Santa pere lachaise you
know skilled use of my plan now that's
my that's my album right here but the
new album I can't stop listening to it
yeah yeah kildee I always played at the
meet-and-greets I had a plan a day it
just gives me a certain feeling but this
one man I play like at night before I go
to sleep you know send during the day
you know if sizzling I just can't get
all sixes and sevens out of my deck it's
uh it's crazy because it's like you you
or you're getting you know it seems like
album to album you get better as an MC
and you put out better music up for a
lot of people it's kind of the yeah
that's a crazy well because you always
fear that you know the older you get you
might start getting rusty man but I I no
rhythm man you know I'm sizzling rhythm
is my thing so I can't even see myself
going down right I'm sizzling like maybe
I'll get corny one day who knows I don't
know what corny is you know I mean
because I'm what my stuff was pretty
gritty you know I mean and I'm I'm
always gonna have that sexual and then
I'm always gonna have that night I am i
psycho is my oh yeah I'm all gonna have
the psycho element you know Sam b.o.b
and Hobson killed it people probably
like gops our song and then hehe I mean
cuz you know a lot of people who don't
follow you'll be closely things like a
pop artist yeah I McCullough is better
he's popular but yeah but which is cool
we don't hear but I'm you know he did
the beat yeah and he did the core is so
how's that for your pop star and uh I'd
like too much love for the old-school
reference in the beginning I like you oh
yeah yeah Frank the tank that's it he's
great I love you but you're crazy you
know will feel friends what's your
favorite our favorite song on the album
it's a lot of songs on the album yes a
lot of songs is 24 selections then the
bonus cuts the one with pill I liked
all your pills on there that's right um
I don't know man I got a lot of them man
the one with me in the deftones if I
could that personal one really the one
with mint condition on it boogie man but
produced by the Justice League I love
that one I can't stop listening and he's
a mental giant he's a mental giant the
second verse is just I can't believe I
wrote it yeah I was in awe statistic
hard to grip it dark and wicked arts
prolific Mars with the Stars this is far
lifted livers quick the ball but the
boss scriptures are terrific did I spit
out with a bit of better market it would
it's gonna benefit the honey liqueur
start the twisted could have said in
Shiva in the slitters little spill you
know saying it's just going you know
yeah it's definitely a great album and
uh you know we just saw online that you
were talking that I think it was MTV or
something to ask you if the majors have
been knocking and of course they have
been totally and and you you were saying
that in your you know your ear I guess
your plan is for strange music to be a
major oh that's what this was that's
what's happening right now man you know
we signed j-roc you know who says Landry
night he was he was on Warner yeah you
know same way too late May Day we just
saw made a note sent a band from miami
florida we just signed stevie stone he
was on with you yeah yeah he was but he
was time to ruthless when he was on tour
with me before on the KO dito or
whatever you know I'm sizzling and we
just we just it's getting bigger
management you know we got brother Lynch
hung we a lot of people don't know we
got young bleed now from Melanie yeah
familiar and so it's like we just move
and dog and and and just good music as
will always prevail I think you know I
mean is there anything in particular
that like that that you're planning on
doing her that you think you need to do
to like I guess take it to that next
level where strange music is like you
know I think it's I think it's this
album the awareness of this album you
know me having a number four spot and
Lady Gaga being number one or Adele
being number two in search of Mormons
via number three that should have been
my spot yeah if I would have sold my
album for what like 199 on something
well that's another thing is like like
like you
amazon i think it lady gaga's I'm for
Dorne yes see they have to do tricks you
gotta buy you know what I'm saying like
you know let's come your fans by by
yourself yeah I wish other side of that
trick no but it's good they still play
pay money for mine and I'm still in the
top five you know yeah and I'm
independent with no radio no video so
that's like that's a bigger statement
you know I'm sizzling like whoa most
definitely you know I mean and when they
told me I was like that means we're
doing the right thing so I think what
this album is gonna be a lot of
awareness you know some people are gonna
start being familiar after this i'm
about to work on a collabo CD called
strange land with all our artists you
know I'm said Linda I'm gonna do my rock
album dope song and album too yeah yeah
yeahs Justice League man gave me okay I
got the stuff from justice league that I
that fits in my world yeah i'm saying i
love the stuff they do for Drake I love
the stuff they do for Rick Ross I love
what they did on the Teflon Don album
not sure I told them that when I met him
I'm like that's what I'm talking about
Sam but what I chose strange land music
you know so it's wonderful I just think
a lot of people are going to pay
attention now man and now it's time to
show my butt you know um a collabo that
was everyone's been asking for four
years as you and em I heard that that
was supposed to have only ER but it
didn't it didn't happen did it did it
like did it was the song gun right no no
no Royce looked it up Royce Royce hook
this up and M said he would love to do
the song we said its home and everything
and he said I'd love to do it he's like
yeah I got that I got that give me a
couple weeks anna paul rosenberg call
back like it might be like a month I'm
like oh my my my my yesterday my
mastering date was coming up in like two
weeks so I had to like me okay next time
I'm saying no hard feelings or nothing
you know if sizzling so but at least I
list the wheels are in motion it's gonna
it's gonna happen it's not a hat that's
cool but you know saying uh yeah I hope
so man you know the bees got to speak to
me though that beat spoke to me yeah and
luckily there was another brother that I
think could hold that need hell did very
well blind fury you know I'm sitting he
saved the song you know I'm saying yeah
that's another thing I want to ask you
about is on your album like you you put
like a worldwide choppers it had Twista
you know Ted or yourself Busta and
yellow pillow on it and then put a bunch
of other
mcs i never heard you so from denmark
chaise up from Turkey Jael from be hood
Kansas City Missouri deal oak the guild
God from Kansas City Kansas and twisted
insane from cali you know I'm so I'm a
chopper I mean I'm in the street right
so so did you kind of do that on purpose
to kind of like yeah you know cuz you
know a lot of people going to hear that
songs yeah I let I let the world know
that who the top choppers are tiny you
know I'm saying it will be the guy on
the highest you know not at the top of
totem pole on the bottom you know I'm
saying it's like some of these guys on
here you never heard of right now I'm
saying but they go just like the guys up
here and I don't even say I don't care
yeah like if we get into the song i
think it's the turkey dude is like what
the hell yeah let's change the spitting
at arabic man like here we go I don't
know how because I worked with taser
before you know I got a song called dark
places with him that they put out in
Turkey you know I'm saying it's like you
got excuse me sound so tired I just got
back from Astros so I'm laid-back wide
like a couple of glasses of reisling
some you know some swarf